Hello, everyone. Welcome to a new episode of The
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Ricard Lops, and
today I'm joined by Dr. Ryan Burge. He's professor
of practice at the John C. Dunforth Center at
Washington University in St. Louis. And today we're going
to talk about his book The Vanishing Church, How
the Hollowing Out of moderate congregations is Hurting democracy,
faith, and us. So Dr. Burge, welcome to the
show. It's a pleasure to everyone.
Thanks so much for having me.
OK, so, um, what would you say is moderate
religion? I mean, what characterizes moderate religious people?
Yeah, so the, the subtitle of the book is,
you know, holling out a moderate congregations. I, I
don't mean that in those congregations that everyone is
a moderate. Um, YOU know, if we, if we
think of political ideology as a scale from 1
to 10, you know, 1 being very liberal and
10 being very conservative, I'm not talking about a
congregation where everyone's a 5. I'm talking about a
congregation where for every 1 there's a 10 and
for every 2 there's a 9, and for every
6 there's a 4. You know, the, the, the
aggregate number averages out to, you know, 45, or
6, somewhere in the middle of, of the spectrum.
And this is what I've realized, uh, after writing
this book is that my definition of moderate is
not pleasing to the 9s and 10s, nor the
1s and 2s. You know, for instance, when I
say, you know, the, the view that two men
should have the right to be married is a
moderate view, um, evangelicals would strongly reject that statement.
Um, AND, and, but my approach, and this is
where my work really struggles with people of faith,
is that I approach these topics from a lens
of social science, not a lens of theology or
philosophy. Um, THEY want to approach it with a
philosophical lens, and my, my definition of moderate is
if most Americans agree with a position, then that
is empirically a moderate position to have. Um, AND
I think that that is what rubs up against
a lot of the, the people on each side,
the kind of the ones and twos and nines
and tens of the debate.
Yeah, I know that that clarification was important because
it's not the way I think most people tend
to think about moderate politics when they hear that
term. I mean they usually, I mean when they
hear something or a position. That, uh, they look
at as being, uh, diametrically opposed to theirs. They
tend to think it's part of the opposite end
of the political spectrum, usually,
right? I think the other thing about moderate though,
it's, it's not just a position, it's a posture,
right? A moderate posture is a posture that says,
I'm willing, I know what my ideal outcome is,
my ideal policy, but I also understand that I
cannot achieve my ideal policy in the world that
we live in, right? You know, for instance, let's
say that you have a position that, you know,
sperm plus egg equal human, um, which would mean
that, you know, IVF should be illegal, um. You
know, any form of abortion should be illegal, whether
it be through rape or incest or for any
reason should be illegal. I think we all understand
in the modern political climate that, that position is
not politically viable. You're not gonna get that passed,
um, really at any level. So the question is,
do you compromise? And then how much do you
Compromise on an issue like that. So for me,
also a moderate is a posture of compromise, saying
that I, if I can move 11 click closer
to my desired policy, then I will vote for
that, you know, as opposed to, unless you give
me all 10 clicks, I will vote for nothing.
Um, I think that's a part of what moderate
means as well, not just where you are in
the 1 to 10 spectrum, but how willing you
are to, to, to be malleable in your positions
at the same time.
So I mean, particularly atheists, and I'm an atheist
myself, I mean, it's very common for us to
look at religion and assuming that all religious people
are necessarily conservative, but there are also progressive and
or liberal religious sects,
correct? Yeah, no, that's I will say that in
America, you know, religion has, is, is seen as
conservative sort of by default, you know, if you're
a religious person, like the, you know, odds are
you're probably a right, a right of center person
depending on how far right of center you are,
um, but there are, I mean, there, there used
to be a lot more liberal religious people in
America. I mean, uh, you know, not to go
too far down the rabbit hole, but 100 years
ago, the most dominant strain of Christian theology was
the social gospel. Which was this idea that God
wanted people to be fed and clothed and taken
care of, you know, from, uh, the forty-hour work
week, you know, union rights, uh, child labor laws,
overtime rules, uh, prohibition were all pushed by social
gospelers who wanted to try to make the world.
Uh, A better place, more like heaven on earth.
And, and so that, you know, that was the
world that we live in right now in America
with American religion and politics is a very modern
incarnation of the relationship between the two things. And
religion is not by default a conservative thing, by
the way. I mean, I think in the current
era, it's seen that way, but it's not. Throughout
American history, it's not always been that way. So
a lot of what I tell my students and
when I give, you know, discussions is I say,
it's not always been this way. You know, if
you go back 50, 60 years in history, you'll
see a lot more diversity in American Christianity, especially,
uh, especially white American Christianity. I mean, there used
to be a lot of Democrat-white Christians out there
and they're sort of uh, an endangered species now.
Yeah, and I mean, even historically we know that
there were many religious movements and religious sects associated
with progressive politics and progressive movements in, in the
19th century, for example, uh related to abolitionism in
the 60s, related to uh civil rights and all
of that, right?
Oh, that, that's, that, those. The younger people in
America don't know anything about. And was driven largely
by people of faith. The civil rights movement was,
and I think we teach civil rights in America
sort of one dimensionally. It's When really it was
a, there was a religious fervor involved in a
spirituality involved in the civil rights, and if you,
if you read the writings of the civil rights
reformers like Martin Luther King Junior, he was a
pastor, you know. Religious imagery and religious language, uh,
and we sort of forget that, I think. You
know, we kind of make it into all about
politics and secular things, but you don't walk across
a bridge into a, uh, an, an army of
guards with dogs unless you believe there's something beyond
this world, you know, that there's something motivating you.
And I think that's, that, that's the aspect that
if you're Not a person of faith. It's hard
to teach. It's hard to talk about because it
sort of operates in this realm that is illogical
and irrational and doesn't really follow the rules of
science. So that's what makes social science hard and
wonderful is it sort of operates in this liminal
space between what we can understand and count and,
and, and see and touch, but also something that's
sort of beyond all those things.
Mhm. So in the book you go through the
through how the religious landscape in America has changed
over the past 50 years since the 1970s, including
the trajectory of Protestant Christianity, Catholicism, the rise of
the nuns. So I would like to ask you
about the trends. Uh, IN regards to which of
those sects. So, uh, when it comes to the
evangelicals, I mean, who are the evangelicals and how
have they grown in the US? I mean, I
think it's very important for us to talk about
them because at least, I, I, I mean, I
live in Europe. I, I, I don't know exactly.
How things are there in the US if you
look at things exactly the same way, but we
tend to associate evangelical Christianity a lot with conservative
political figures like Donald Trump and others. So is
that the same way you look at it,
or no, there's The most conservative political group in
America today are white evangelicals, without a doubt. I
mean, 81, 83% of them vote for Donald Trump.
I mean, and You don't get a group that's
that politically unified, that's that large, uh, in American.
You can find little smaller groups that may be
90%, you know, one or the other. But I
mean, evangelicals in America make up 20% of the
population. There's somewhere around 70 to 75 million evangelicals,
uh, in America. About 40% of all of Donald
Trump's votes in 2024 came from the evangelicals. So
I mean, it's, there is no more important religious
group in American politics than, than evangelicals, like full
stop. And it, it, that will continue for decades
in the future. Um, EVANGELICALS make up 20% of
the population. Uh, THEY were 20% of the population
50 years ago. So that, you know, the size
of the group is actually about the same. Uh,
SO when people talk about religious decline in America,
you gotta be more specific, right? Some groups have
declined, you know, pretty noticeably, and other groups haven't
really. And I think white evangelicals sort of fit
in the category of no, they're doing, they're doing
quite fine, uh, from a numeric perspective. And I
think from a cultural perspective, They're actually probably more
impactful today than they were 2030, 40 years ago
because they're sort of one of the last bastions
of American religion that's still strong and vibrant and
growing and multifaceted. But, um, white evangelicals are conservative.
I mean, they've been conservative for a very long
time, by the way. The question that I really
struggle with is why do so many evangelicals vote
for Donald Trump? Well, the answer is because he's
a Republican. I mean, 75% of them voted for
McCain in 2008, you know, so it's the, the
white evangelical vote is a Republican vote, you know,
so whoever you put in, in that, on the
ticket with a Republican after their name, that's who
white evangelicals are gonna vote for, you know, whether
it be McCain or Romney, who is a Latter-day
Saint, or, or Trump or whoever comes after Trump,
it's gonna be 75 to 80%, you know, voting
for that person. So from that perspective, it's, Now,
why do they like him so much? Uh, THAT'S
a question I don't think I have a great
answer for, um. He has a charisma that's hard
to describe to a non-American. I'll just say that.
Um, WE always are, are drawn to these very
like proud, strong, aggressive figures, and that's what Donald
Trump is. Evangelicals are predisposed to liking people like
that, sort of like a strongman figure in American
politics, and we Time. So, yeah, I think that's
part of it. It's personality driven.
Mhm, RIGHT, and I, and I mean, uh, is
it that, uh, you say that they voted for
Donald Trump because he was on the Republican side,
uh, uh, I mean, do you think that if
he, if he had run for the Democrats, I
mean, if he was on the Democrat side, of
course it's really hard to, to imagine Donald Trump
as a. Democrat, but anyway, do you think that
if he was a Democrat or an independent, that
they wouldn't have voted for him? I mean, maybe
because the kind of conservatism that he expresses politically
is not exactly in line with the conservatism associated
with evangelical Christians, or, or is it?
I think he's remade what conservativism means in American
life. And I think that's the, that's the part
that's hard to describe to someone who hasn't followed
American politics closely, but, you know, the American, the,
the American Republican Party of 20 years ago was
a free trade party, was a sort of hawkish
interventionist foreign policy party. Uh, YOU know, George HW
Bush, George W. Bush is kind of the prototypical,
you know, compassionate conservatism, but definitely conservativism, right? Not
super xenophobic, um, but, you know, family values, religious
values, things like that. That was sort of a
moderate, you know, the median Republican, and now the
Republican Party is anti-free trade. Um, WHICH is, you
know, so antithetical to what like conservatism was in
America. Um, THEN Trump's had this very interesting foreign
policy, right, which he said, he's like, we're done
with foreign wars. We're not gonna be, you know,
adventuring all over the world. And then he, you
know, invades Venezuela and removes the dictator, and then
he, you know, bombs Iran. So, you know, it's
like you can't figure out what can, and then
not even on abortion, you know, he's, he's moderated
on abortion too. Obviously, it's illegal at the federal
level, but at the state level, he said, I
want states to have the right to do whatever
they want, you know, including allowing abortion at the
state level. So, in many ways, he kind of
cuts across what we think conservativism is, and he's
remade conservativism. So we actually have a term called
MAGA, you know, in America, are you a MAGA
Republican? OR are you sort of like an old-school
Republican, a normie Republican? And I think, you know,
MAGA has taken over and MAGA has taken over
evangelicalism too. There's not a whole lot of normie
evangelicals out there anymore. They're much more the Donald
Trump style. The question though is, after Trump leaves
the stage, what is the Republican Party? You know,
does it kind of revert back to what it
was 20 years ago or has it been permanently
remade in the image of Donald Trump and MA
politics? We just don't have an answer to right
now.
Mhm. In the book you also talk about trends,
how trends have looked like for mainline Protestants. So
what, what have they looked like over the past
few decades?
Yeah, bad. I think that's the, the easiest way
to describe it is bad, uh, and worse in
many ways than, than even people think it is.
Uh, MAINLAND Protestants were about half of America in
the 1950s. Um, 52% of Americans were mainline Protestants
in 1958. Um, AND by 1975, it dropped to
30%, and today it's less than 10%, somewhere about
8-9% of Americans, uh, are mainline Protestant. It was
the sort of the proudest, most dominant religious tradition
in America for most of the 20th century, and
now it's not, obviously, and sort of sliding toward,
um, extinction in many ways. If you look at
demographics, I mean, Uh, the Episcopalians, half of them
are over the age of 65. Uh, YOU know,
these, a lot of these denominations average age is
in the 60s. So, you know, they're not long
for this world. A lot of denominations are gonna
lose 30, 40, 50% of their members in the
next 20 years because of death. Um, YOU know,
there's very few, only 5% of Generation Z identifies
as mainline Protestant. So that, you know, the future
is just not very bright. Now, a lot of
those denominations have a lot of institutional wealth though.
It's been sort of piling up for generations and
decades. The Episcopal Church in America can trace its
history back 400 years. You know, it was given
land by the Queen in the 1600s. So there's
a lot of like sort of ancestral money in
the Those denominations, they're gonna be zombie denominations though,
in many ways, where they have a lot of
money but not a lot of people. So, you
know, what do you do in a situation like
that where you have a building that's humongous and
only has 30 people in worship. So, the mainline
has definitely lost its cultural relevance too because young
people don't even know what a mainline Protestant is.
You know, you talk about what Protestant is, they
think evangelicalism by default. They don't understand Methodism or
Episcopalians or Presbyterians. When those gene, you know, those
groups ran America for, for most of our history,
now they're just, they're just a rounding error in
the grand sweep of American religion.
How about American Catholics? I mean, I'm Portuguese. I'm
living here in Portugal. Even though I'm an atheist,
the country is still, I mean, the majority of
the country is still Catholic. So, but here there
in the US, how have trends looked like for
Catholics?
So Catholics were very steady for a very long
time, right around 25 to 27% of the population
almost every year, very consistent. From the 1970s all
the way to about 2010 or so, and then,
um, the data says that the share of Americans
are Catholic has dropped about 5% points in the
last 15 years. They're down to about 20 to
22% of America, so down from a high of
27 or so. Um, SO there's still a ton
of Catholics in America, 62 million according to their
own records. Um, THEY'RE all over, you know, it's,
it's hard to find a part of America that
does not have a Catholic Church. I think pretty
much every county in America has a Catholic Church.
Um, BUT they're growing more racially diverse. You know,
I think that's the biggest story in American Catholicism
is they were overwhelmingly white 50 years ago. And
now if you look at Generation Z, you know,
40% of the Gen Z Catholics are Hispanic. So,
you know, it's, it's a changing religious group in
America. And so there's a, there's a weird power
dynamic happening right now is how much are white
Catholics willing to give up, sort of the, the
leadership of their church and give it over to,
to non-white Catholics. Um, POLITICALLY speaking, the Catholic Church
has, you know, for a long time it was
Democratic. You know, the John F. Kennedy Democrats was
a, was a huge part of the Democratic Party.
And now, white Catholics are a solidly red voting
bloc. About 2/3 of white Catholics voted for Donald
Trump. In 2024, even like 42% of non-white Catholics
voted for Donald Trump. So now the Catholic voting
bloc is 55, 45%, 55% Republican. So it's, it
used to be very divided. I used to always
say that America looks like Catholics and Catholics like
America, like at the voting booth. And that's not
true anymore. Now, it's, they're, they're a right-leaning constituency
in America. But what's overriding all that is that
the average Catholic is not that devout. You know,
only 25% of Catholics report going to mass, uh,
every Sunday. It used to be 50% of Catholics
were weekly massgoers. So a lot of cultural Catholicism
in America, not sort of like theological Catholicism.
Mm. And what about the nuns or how, I
mean, that's the word sociologists, for example, and some
political scientists used to refer to people who, if
I understand it correctly, do not identify as being
part of any of any main religious sect. I
mean, And we have to be careful here because
sometimes, as I said, I'm an atheist, and sometimes
atheists speak on the percentages of nun of people
identified as nuns in the several different countries to
make an argument that they are all atheists, but
they're actually not. I mean, they can be agnostics,
they can be part. I guess smaller religious sects
or they can be spiritual people. So, uh, how
have the trends for the nuns looked like over
the past few decades in the US?
So the nuns have grown exponentially in America. They
were 5% of the country. Uh, IN 1991, and
today they're about 30% of America. Uh, IT'S the,
the most significant religious movement in, you know, recent
American religious history without a doubt. Um, YOU'RE talking
25% of Americans now, uh, just increased 25%. Um,
AND the interesting thing about the nuns is that
most nuns are not atheists. You know, I think
that's a very important point that if If you
put 5 non-religious people in a room, 1 is
an atheist, one's an agnostic, and 3 are people
who call themselves nothing in particular. That's literally the
option on the survey. They look at all the
options, and it's, it's sort of the none of
the above, uh, category in American religion. These are,
these are people who obviously aren't Protestant or Catholic
or Jewish or Muslim, but also they're not atheists
or agnostics either. They sort of shrug their shoulders
in American religion. They're apathetic towards American religion, either,
either direction, either being an atheist or being a
Protestant or Catholic. Um, AND there's nothing in particular
among young people. Actually, the most popular response option
is nothing in particular. About 1/3 of 18 to
22 year olds described their religion as nothing in
particular. And it's growing, you know, I mean, we,
we gotta keep this in mind. Like 1 out
of 5 Americans is nothing in particular now. Atheists
are 5%, you know, so it's the atheists get
all the play, right? They get all the media
attention, all the discussions about atheism as an idea.
But if you actually sit back and look at
the data, then nothing in particulars are really the
story. They're gonna win you elections. They're gonna change
society like in a way that atheist agnostics, um,
could not yet, you know, atheist agnostics are much
more liberal politically speaking than nothing in particulars. Atheists
are The most liberal group we have in America
from a pure empirical standpoint are atheists on social
issues. It's, it's atheists and agnostics are sort of
slightly less liberal, but still liberal, but slightly less
liberal than atheists. Uh, Nothing in particular are to
the left of the political spectrum, but sort of
center left politically speaking. They're, you know, 65% Democrat
voting bloc while atheists are 85% Democratic voting bloc.
Um, SO, and we also see some evidence right
now that the share of Americans who are non-religious
has stopped increasing. Uh, IN the last couple of
years and maybe even decreased in some surveys. So,
you know, the rise of the nuns is over,
you know, effectively speaking for now at least.
Right. So I mean, looking at all those trends,
what can we tell about, uh, I mean, the
claims made by certain people that religion is on
the decline? Of course, I mean when people make
those claims, sometimes they are referring. To America specifically.
Other times they are referring to other countries and
even other times they are referring to just global
trends. But I mean, is there really, uh, is
religion really on the decline, uh, specifically in the
US?
I would say it's on a pause right now.
Um, IT definitely declined between 1990 and 2020, you
know, in a very significant way. And it's, there's,
there's a, we're not, where it's sort of the
calm before the storm. We're gonna see secularism continue
in America going forward because of generational replacement. You
know, boomers are 20% non-religious and Gen Z are
40% non-religious. And what's gonna happen. On a massive
scale in the next 20 years, boomers are gonna
die, um, by the tens of millions of them.
And the people that replaced them in surveys are
gonna be Gen Z and Gen Z is half
as religious as boomers are. So that means the
number of nuns, the share of Americans who are
non-religious is going, it's going to inevitably rise in
the next 15 to 20 years. It's not rising
now though because those boomers are still sort of
like holding back the, the wave of secularism that's
happening right now. Um, THE, the, the information about
other countries is a lot harder to parse, to
be honest with you. There's a lot of mixed
messaging. There's this report that came out of, uh,
you know, the UK called the Quiet Revival. It
showed a huge jump in religion which ended up
being methodologically problematic. Um, YOU know, the problem about
measuring religion around the world is, is, is concepts
don't travel perfectly from one country to another country,
right? To say you're religious and India is not
to say you're religious in, you know, in Ireland.
Like those are just two different concepts, you know,
the idea of going to a house of worship
means different things to different religious groups. So, it
really is hard to sort of measure what's happening.
I think we can all admit that secularism, you
know, had this unbelievable run, but that run is
probably slowing down, if not stopping in most parts
of the world right now. Not that we're gonna
see a massive return to faith in the world.
I don't think that's in the cards, but definitely
of more slow growth in in the nuns across
the world than we saw the last 30 years.
Yeah, definitely we have to keep in mind cross
cultural differences in how people approach religion and religiosity
and how they identify or think about themselves as
being part of a religious sect or not, so
we, we definitely have to keep that in mind
when Looking at the data. So, uh, and you
talk about the trend of polarization in American religion.
I mean, what does polarization mean in this particular
context and how has that played out?
Yeah, so polarization is sort of like really amorphous,
uh, a term that we sort of slap on
everything at this point. But what it really means
from, you know, a numerical perspective is that, you
know, it's, it's more and more people going from
being, you know, 45, and 6 on that on
ideological distribution to being 8s and 9s and 10s
and 1s and 2s and 3s, right? It's moving
toward the edges of the political spectrum and away
from the middle of the political spectrum. It's hotly
debated in America, just like what, how that's happening,
what level that's, is it even happening is actually
a huge debate. Uh, IN America, when I was
in grad school, it was like probably the biggest
debate in American politics was, are we polarizing and
at what level? You know, there's a debate that
we're, uh, the elites are polarizing. So the partisans,
like the, the party elites are polarizing left and
right. Um, IS that actually trickling down to the
rank and file people, you know, the average American,
are they polarizing? How much is that sort of
like sliding down the hill and, and changing us?
Institutionally speaking, I think there's, it's hard to look
at the evidence and say we're not polarized. I
mean, you know, when you look at white evangelicals
and the share of Republicans now is higher than
ever, you know, it's been the last 50 years
and, you know, you look at atheists, they're going
the other direction. So you do see some sort
of organization, institutional polarization, but there's something even more
insidious, but I don't talk about that much in
the book, which is effective polarization, which is the
idea that you don't vote. For your candidate, you
hate the other party, and that's why you vote
for the party you vote for, you know, I
mean, you know, you hear this a lot in
the American political discourse. I heard a, a conservative
commentator the other day said, I don't care if
Donald Trump drops nuclear weapons on Iran. The Democrats
are evil. You know, like it's, it's this idea
of like, I could never vote for this party,
so I have to vote for that party and
I hate the other party. So I think a
lot of it is that effective polarization thing is
where we sort of demonize the other side. And
then it justifies our, a lot, you hear a
lot of evangelicals say this in America, by the
way. I'm not voting for Donald Trump. I'm voting
against the evilness of the Democratic Party. Um, YOU
know, if that's true or not, I, I don't
know. I think for some of them it is.
I think a lot of them, it's a way
to not say what they really believe, which is
they really do like Donald Trump. They really like
his politics. They really like his policies. They really
like him as a person. So, you know, that
that's the hard thing to parse is like what
goes through a voter's mind when they go cast
a ballot. You know, I don't think any of
us have a, even me, you know, like why
do I, why do I vote for this person,
not for that person? I say our job, political
science is the dumbest job in the world because
we try to figure out what goes on through
someone's mind when they walk into the voting booth
on election day. And, you know, for some people,
it could be an incredibly sophisticated discussion, right, about
policy and, you know, and, and, and priorities and
philosophy and theology and all these things. And for
someone, it could be they walked in the room
and they were drunk and they hit the wrong
button. You know, it's, it's our job to try
to figure out like what causes the votes to
happen. So polarization is, is, is just the idea
that the society is sort of like moving toward
the edges, the fringes of the political spectrum, and
moving away from the middle of American politics.
So if there's this polarization in American society and
American politics as you argue in your book, what
would you say led to it?
It's hard to not blame it on the media
at some level. You know, you got to think
to yourself like, OK, 30 years ago, we were
fairly politically, uh, moderate. There's a lot of compromise,
even like in Ronald Reagan's presidency, there's a lot
of like, Ronald Reagan would, would play golf with
Tip O'Neill and, and Reagan was a Democrat, and
Tip O'Neill was a, I'm sorry, Reagan was a
Republican, Tip O'Neill was a Democrat, right? You would
never see that today. You know, the Democrats don't,
don't even want to look at the Republicans and
vice versa. And a lot of it is the
24 hour news cycle. You know, I, I think
there's a lot to be laid at the blame
of, you know, having to produce content 24 hours
a day, 7 days a week, means you're gonna
have to, you know, and politicians lean into this,
by the way. You know, they want to create
that good content. They wanna get that sound bite
on TV and a lot of it's just call
the other party evil and bad and bad for
America and anti-American. And what that leads us to
sort of a, a downward spiral is if you
say we're evil, we're gonna say you're evil. You
know, and, and to go back and forth like
that. So, I do think at some level, it
is, it is the media, and then that's been
sort of um turbocharged by social media, which is,
I don't know if you can be more than
24/7, but somehow social media, it feels like it's
more than 24/7, right? It's just, it's just running
continuously. And the amount of information that comes out
on social media is just staggering, even compared to
cable news. So, I do think that social media,
and now we can with, with, you know, the
algorithms, we can curate our feeds in such a
way where we only see what we want to
see about, you know, each party. We don't want
to hear, we never hear an alternative view of
the other party. We only find another reason to
hate them. And I think a lot of influencers
are being, you know, being incentivized, to be quite
honest with you, to lean into their left-leaning audience
or right-leaning audience. And the algorithm will give, wants
to keep you on the platform. And how do
they do that by giving you the content that
you want. Um, AND so I think that's kind
of created this terrible feedback loop where a lot
of Republicans don't see anything good in the Democrats.
And a lot of Democrats don't see anything good
in the Republicans cause the algorithm shows them nothing
but bad things about the other party. So, I
do think at some level, we have to blame
at least some of this on the media and
then social media, how it changed the Americans' information
diet over the last 30 years.
And so, in what ways does this sort of
uh social and political polarization relate to religious polarization
in the US?
Yeah, it's, you know, we, we kind of touched
on this a little bit earlier, but, you know,
you could be a white Christian Democrat 30 years
ago. There were lots of them, you know, Bill
Clinton won a whole bunch of them in 1992
and 1996. Um, A lot of people voted for
Jimmy Carter, you know, in 1970, a lot of
evangelicals voted for Jimmy Carter in 1976 cause he
was an evangelical. Um, SO what it's done is
it's sort of purified American religion, and you see
a lot of rhetoric about this, by the way,
like the Democratic Party is the party of the
devil. It's an evil party, it's anti-Christian. They're gonna
kill your babies and trans your kids. I mean,
you do see that rhetoric all the time in
American social media. That's what the Democratic Party stands
for. They hate every, there's a phrase I see
on social media all the time that makes me
want to jump off a cliff, which says, you
don't hate these people enough. Like they're, they want
you to to be driven away from the other
party. And in many ways, you know, we want
to believe that religion is the primary philosophical lens
that people have in America, but I don't think
that's true. I think politics is first and religion
sort of lives behind that. And so actually a
lot of people are choosing what church to go
to based on their politics or how often they
go or what type of, you know, faith they
have is based on their politics. And, and, and
the thing about American religion that I think a
lot of journalists miss. They want to tell tons
of stories about how lots of people left evangelicalism
because they're liberal and evangelicalism is conservative, but actually
evangelicalism has gained a lot of people who are
conservative. You know, it's actually been attractive to some
people. That's the other side of the coin, right?
People go, why are evangelicals doing this? Well, because
it's actually, it, it might not be as bad
as you think it is in terms of numbers.
So, I think there are a lot of people,
they don't have any concept of American religion that's
not conservative and therefore, we're sorting ourselves out. So
now the nuns, right? Usually the Democratic Party, you
cannot rely on non-religious voters to win you anything
cause there weren't enough of them. And now, 45%
of Harris voters were non-religious. In 2024. So like,
now the Democratic Party is leaning into the nuns
because they realized that's a base of power for
them and the Republican Party is leaning into conservative
Christians because that's a base of power for them.
So, you know, the size of each group has
made it more amenable for these two groups to
sort themselves out as well. So, You know, now
we have what's called the God gap. You know,
the idea of the Republican Party is a party
of religious people and the Democrats, the party of
non-religious people, and that gap is just gonna become
more hardened and more part of American life in
the future, and young people are just gonna have
no concept, right? Before when it was 90% Christians
were evenly divided, Democrats and Republicans. That just seems
like bizarre today from what it used to be.
Uh, IS there a divide when it comes to,
uh, how religious people, people are, I mean, comparing
the more religious people to the less religious people,
is there a divide in terms, uh, of their
wealth and level of education in America?
Yeah, so a lot of people have this perception,
uh, of religion that it's for sort of poor,
uneducated people, and I think, I think people read
too much Karl Marx back in the day, you
know, that, that religion is sort of like this,
the opiate of the masses, right? It's a tool
of oppression for dumb people, you know, like. And
you see this, by the way, Karl Marx writes
about this all the time. Like the, the, the,
the rich factory owner takes advantage of the workers
and says, well, you know, God wants you to
work hard. Well, who's gonna get rich if you
work hard? It's the factory owner, not the people,
right? Well, guess what? In America, that whole model
just doesn't work. And actually, one of the clearest
findings in all the data I've ever looked at
is the people who are the most likely to
attend church this weekend will be, be people with
graduate degrees, and the people who are the least
likely are those with a high school diploma or
less. So there's a very strong positive relationship between
education. Attendance, uh, in the United States. I, I
think we forget that, right? That, that, that it's
people in America have realized that to be a
polite citizen, to be an upwardly mobile, you know,
active member of the community means to be part
of a religious group. I see the value in
being part of a religious group because that's where
the establishment is in a lot of small towns
across America. You need to be part of that
big church to have a, a, a veterinarian or
insurance salesman or a real estate agent or to
run for political office or, you know, whatever it
is, like you want to be part of that
crew. And so, you know, American religion is, is
quite, quite literally, uh, uh, you know, part of
the privileged set of American people. And there's a,
and I don't write about this a ton in
the book, but I write about this in other
places. You know, there's a very clear through line
in the data which is that dropping out leads
to more dropping out. You know, so dropping out
of religion is actually indicative of dropping out of
education. It's, it's indicative of dropping out of politics.
There's nothing in particular we just talked about, right?
Huge group, growing group in America. They're the least
level of education of any religious group in America.
They're the least politically active of any religious group
in America. Um, AND obviously, they're non-religious. So, you
know, like, they're just pulling away from all the
vestiges of a, a polite society. Meanwhile, educated people
are, are, are leaning in, you know, they're being
actually more engaged and more involved. So it's like
sort of like this, things are going both directions
at one time and it's like the rich get
richer in all ways, not just financial, the rich
get richer and the poor get poorer, and that
gap is only growing over time.
So do you think that this problem of religious
polarization in America and how that then manifests at
a more societal and political level, it can be
solved? I mean, can religion become less polarized and
if so, do you have any idea of how
that could happen or could be done?
That's the question I get asked with the most
frequency that I don't have. A clear answer to,
to be honest. Um, IT'S, I, I've always said,
if you said, well, you know, I was a
pastor for 20 years, and if you would ask
me, would I rather lead a church of, you
know, cultural diversity and political diversity or a church
where everyone voted for the same candidate and basically
the same views of the world, it'd be so
much easier to lead that unified church, you know,
cause they all agree, you know, you say certain
things and they all kind of go, yeah, amen,
brother, let's go, you know, like. It's harder to
lead diverse organizations. It's, it's just a fact. And
so I always say that like what I'm actually
asking religion to do is bad for religion but
good for democracy, right? Which is to become more
politically heterogeneous, more diverse, you know, age-wise, race-wise, income-wise,
education-wise. Um, I don't think there's a magic bullet,
you know, to say, hey, let's, we're all a
bunch of Republicans, let's invite some Democrats to come
hang out with us, or a bunch of old
people, let's invite young people, or, you know, we're
a bunch of college educated people. Let's invite people
with high school diplomas. Like it, it doesn't work
right because religion is a voluntary organization, you know,
you, you show up if you want to and
you pick what church you want to, and you
come in when you want to. So I, I
think part of it is though, is I've been
telling pastors that the goal they should have. IS
to try to give people a coherent worldview to
think about things that are happening in American politics
and society, and not necessarily a partisan worldview. You
know, I think that the good, the good, a
good preacher afflicts the comfortable and comforts the afflicted.
And you got to do both in equal measure.
It it's so much easier to comfort people than
to afflict them. But I think we all need
to be afflicted sometimes, right? When you be told
we're not doing good enough and the, the people
that we think are the politicians we vote for
maybe not be moral upstanding citizens and all those
things. So I'm actually telling pastors to make their
job harder, which I fully understand as a pastor,
I didn't want my job to be harder. So,
I don't think there's a magic bullet. I think
it starts from the bottom up, you know, I
think it starts for the average like that that
45, and 6 person who isn't going to church
right now needs to show up, needs to become
part of a church, right? Needs to, to lean
into those communities. And I think that's on them,
you know, I think it, it really is a,
a mass movement that has to happen in America.
And I'm not super hopeful that's gonna happen, but
my goal in writing the book was, you know,
reaching out to those 4, 5s, and 6s saying,
hey, you know what, church might be a good
thing for you. You might really benefit from this
in a whole bunch of ways, so you should
probably show up. Whether they actually do or not,
uh, you know, I think that's an open question.
Mhm. OK, so I have one last question and,
and as I told you before, I'm an atheist,
but I'm not an anti-theist, so I, I'm not
necessarily against religion or religious people. Um, I mean,
what would you say, let's see, let's say that
religion in the future. uh, WILL decline further. Uh,
I mean, what would you say could be the
effects, whether social, political, or other kinds of effects
that the decline of the church could have in
in America, in America? Yeah,
yeah, um, I think we just, there's two ways
to approach this. Obviously there's like sort of like
a deep philosophical and theological conversation to be had
about. You know, what's our shared morality if we
don't have Christianity at the core? Cause we've had
American Christianity at the core, you know, for since
the founding, America was founded by Christian people and
has been run by Christian people for our entire
history, right? So if we get rid of that,
what unifies us? You know, like how do we
hold together the disparate pieces? That's, that's a philosophical
question. I'm not super well equipped to answer. I,
I just don't, I don't think about those things
very much. But from a purely social standpoint, I
think we're seeing a more atomized, a more, um,
you know, We're drawing apart from each other. You
know, we're, we're not operating in diverse spaces anymore.
And I think that's the real tragedy of, of
the decline of religion is that for all its
foibles and failures, uh, the American church was always
a place where rich and poor, you know, and,
and, and educated and uneducated, and conservative and liberals
all sat side by side on a Sunday morning
and worship together. And you found out that you
had a whole lot more in common than you
had in difference. You know, and you can work
through your differences because of what you held in
common. So, I think we sort of lost our
ability to know how to compromise because we don't
practice that very often. We don't practice dialogue and
discussion where we used to have these, these debates
at places like church, but also places like, uh,
we have like Elks Clubs and Moose Clubs and
American Legion, like these kind of social organizations where
people would hang out. Um, THOSE are all gone
away, you know, so we're not, we're not as
social as, as we need to be. And I
think that's, that to me is like, uh, even
if you're an atheist and listen to what I
have to say, here's why it matters to you
is America being less social hurts all of us.
You know, I just don't see in any way
that's a positive trend for Democracy, obviously, but also
things like mental health, um, relationships. If we care
about fertility in this country, you know, you've got
to find a partner. And where do you find
a partner in social organizations? Well, they're going away,
so how do you find, you know, so it's,
it's creating sort of all these knock-on effects in
American life. And, you know, you can disagree with
the teachings of Jesus or, or Moses or Muhammad
or Buddha or whatever and still see the value
in social organizations and people meeting together on a
regular basis. And sharing their lives with each other.
And I think that to me is something that's
almost unassailable in the data is this is a
bad thing for all of us. And so how
do we, how do we move past that? How
do we get over that? That is a harder
thing to fix because we've been moving in this
direction for 75 years now. And with more and
more churches closing, there's fewer and fewer opportunities for
that mixing and matching and, and being in diverse
spaces. Uh, AND, and I don't know how we
recover that. At least not, you know, it's not
gonna happen. It doesn't feel like it's gonna happen
in any organic way going forward. And to me,
that's the, that's the red light, the flashing warning
sign in American society right now is just the
collapse of, of social society, not just religious society,
but social society at the same time. And I
don't see how we recover from that in a
meaningful way.
Yeah, so, I mean, are you optimistic or pessimistic
about the future of uh American politics more generally?
It, it depends on the day. I'm not gonna
lie, you know, some days I have days where
I think that this is it, you know, like
we've had a good run, I guess, in America,
and it's all over now. But I, I, I
generally lean toward optimism. Um, I try to at
least. I think like all the winds are blowing
in the pessimistic direction in America, but like I
try to like walk against that wind and say,
no, no, no, there are, there are great and
beautiful and wonderful things happening in America. I think
in many ways we are, we are more economically
prosperous today than we've been at any point in
American history. Technological advancements are just, I mean, the
speed. Uh, THE velocity of technological advancements. And by
the way, most of them coming from the United
States, like, let's be honest about that. I always
tell my students, you know, like, yeah, Europe is
great, but think about the most important inventions in,
in, in the world in the last 25, 30
years. Almost all of them have come from the
United States. And I think there's a lot of
value to say like, we're an innovative culture. We're,
we're always creating and being weird and edgy and
different and, and, and moving things forward. Um, AND
then from a, from a pure like science perspective,
it's really hard to not look at the scientific
community and go, holy cow, we've reached an inflection
point in drug discoveries and therapies that we have
today that we did not have 20 or 30
years ago. You know, if you get cancer 30
years ago, you're 30% more likely to die than
getting cancer today. Uh, WE have a pill that
you can take now that will make you lose
15 to 20% of your body weight with almost
no known side effects. Like, we're, we're solving the
biggest health crisis in America, which is obesity. Like
we have the solution to that now. Like, uh,
you know, we have a cure for cystic fibrosis,
we have a cure for sickle cell anemia. We
have, you know, uh, there are multiple myeloma, 5%,
uh, uh, uh, survival rate 20 years ago. It's
50% today. Like, you look at all this data
and go, why are we so mad about everything?
They're actually not so bad right now. And obviously,
we can talk about geopolitics and all this kind
of stuff, but man. We have a good thing
and, and, and my, my, my posture, at least
my attempted posture is one of hopefulness and, and
gratitude and thanksgiving for all the things that I,
I have that I've been given that my parents
didn't have and their grandparents didn't have. And my
kids are gonna have even more of it than
me. I mean, how, how great is that? So,
the amount of suffering the average average person goes
through in the, in the world today is probably
1/10 of what it was. 100 years ago. Like,
how do you think about that and, and, and
be mad about it? You know what I mean?
So, yeah, we've got problems, but we'll overcome them
because we always overcome our problems. We always always
have. In the history of the world, we've always
overcome our problems in one way or the other.
And we're seeing that in America right now. We're
overcoming some of the biggest challenges, uh, climate change,
you know, we're, we're solar panels, you know, like
we're, we're, we're moving in such a positive direction
that it's just hard to be overtly pessimistic about
the future of America.
Yeah, so let's end on that positive note then.
And the book is again The Vanishing Church How
the Hollowing Out of Moderate Congregations is Hurting democracy,
faith, and us. I will be leaving, leaving a
link to it in the description of the interview.
And Doctor Burge, apart from the book, would you
like to tell people where they can find you
and your work on the internet?
Yeah, so I have a newsletter, sub-stack newsletter called
Graphs About Religion. Graphs about religion.com, new articles every
Monday and Thursday, uh, tons of free content. There
are some paid content, but most of it's free
initially, so you can get a lot of good
content by subscribing to graphs about Religion.com. Doctor Burge.com,
DR Burge.com is my personal website. And uh go
buy the Vanishing Church, which came out just a
couple of months ago, wherever you buy fine books.
Yeah, for sure, so thank you so much for
taking the time to come on the show. It's
been a big pleasure to talk with you.
Well, thank you so much for having me.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights, Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at lights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Mulleran, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingberrd, Arnaud Wolf, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forrest Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegerru Inai Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor,
Michel Stormir, Samuel Andre, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoo, and
Hal Herzognon, Michel Jonathan Labrarinth, John Yardston, and Samuel
Cerri, Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel, Sardusran,
David Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezara Romain Roach, Diego Londono
Correa. Yannik Punteran Ruzmani, Charlotte Blis, Nicole Barbaro, Adam
Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alec Baka Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov,
Zal Adrian Yei Poltontin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward
Hall, Edin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolotti, Gabriel P
Scortez or Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffyani Smith,
and Wisman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg Jarno,
Luke Lovai, Georgios Theophannus, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin, David
Williams, Dio Costa, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex Shaw,
Marie Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D. Lee
Junior. Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber, Robert
Grassy, Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix, Mark
Kempel, Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly Johnson,
Benjamin Galbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael
Bensleyman. George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate Van
Goler, Alexander Obert, Liam Danaway, BR, Massoud Ali Mohammadi,
Perpendicular, Jannes Hetner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David Pinsov,
Sean Nelson, Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A special
thanks to my producers Iar Webb, Jim Frank Lucas
Stink, Tom Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller, Thomas
Trumbull, Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlo Montenegro, Al
Nick Cortiz, and Nick Golden, and to my executive
producers, Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and Rosie.
Thank you for all.